i was going to reflect on the death of
sidney poitier a very famous actor and
at a time when there weren't a lot of
roles for black people in film he
succeeded and he was a breakthrough kind
of guy
but the real story was when robin met
sidney partier i've never forgotten well
let's start from the beginning the
reason robin is the way she is is
because of sidney poitier
i fashioned my own personality based on
who he played in the movie for four
years robin was known as robin poitier i
never took his name no but i called you
robin poitier because i knew all well
in all of the obituaries they said the
regal sidney poitier and i said yeah and
that's why my nickname is queen quivers
because i took on that royal
[Music]
did you attitude that who are you
well you met him at the rain forest
concert in 1997
and i remember that sydney poitier was
very complimentary of your acting in
private parts he felt you were
you should have won best supporting
actress that year well he didn't say
that well i could tell he wanted to say
that i think he felt funny saying it but
i could see it in his eyes
and uh and then he hugged you and kissed
your hand
and uh he said
we should work together absolutely
and then he ran away and she never heard
from him and i didn't say a word because
i was like oh my god this is fitting
well i always felt the two of you i was
trying to write you to a film
but i never got around to it also if you
remember jamie foxx when he was on our
show told us a great story the story was
that jamie foxx
was up for the academy award for playing
ray rachel did a great job
and uh as jamie describes it he was kind
of uh blowing off the oscars in the
sense that you have to campaign for an
oscar and uh oprah said you better uh
come over to my house i want you to meet
someone you want to meet who you
supposed to meet here i said yeah
he's right there
and it was sydney porter i was going to
say i bet you they brought out sydney
party standing in a tuxedo wow like the
classiest guy ever yeah he says
i said hello mr portay i saw you one
time
you were at the party
do you remember that i was like
yeah i'm i'm well enough
he says i want to give you one thing
i want to give you responsibility
when i saw your performance it made me
grow two inches
i was like so i break down
everybody sits me down it was actually
sidney poitier's birthday wow they made
me understand the significance of it
cindy partier first black performer to
win an oscar for best actor that was for
uh lily's of the field i remember that
movie anyway uh i believe robin should
have worked with sydney partier this is
more that's not so much about the other
things that cindy did sydney in a time
when this was just impossible to do he
became
uh the highest paid
actor
the biggest box office actor
in
one year he did
three blockbuster movies yes but this is
more about you you sh you were robbed
you should have had an acting experience
with sidney partier it was put out there
for some reason someone didn't pick up
on it and not your fault i just am happy
to have met him